Film Courage: I think you’ve said previously
Shana that you love to write messy characters?
Why?
Shana Feste, writer/director of BOUNDARIES:
Yeah.
Well, I think I’m a messy person and I grew
up with one of the messiest characters ever
as a father who was just so complicated.
And you know on paper you would look at my
father and think “Oh, my gosh.
Stay away.
Like you got the short stick in the father
department.”
But when you met him and you saw how warm
and charismatic and caring he was, you might
start to change your perspective of him.
So I think those are the most fascinating
characters.
We’re all over the place as human beings
and those are the characters I like writing.
Film Courage: What about playing them?
Did you feel that your characters in the film
were messy?
I know Henry [played by Lewis MacDougall in
Shana Feste’s film BOUNDARIES] was a good
artist, he sure did draw within the lines.
Lewis MacDougall, actor: Henry may be messy,
but you know I don’t think he really cared
and that’s the great thing.
And like you said, he does these amazing drawings,
these very explicit drawings.
You know, he’s a very unique guy.
I enjoyed playing him a lot.
Vera Farmiga, actor: I love messy characterizations
and my character would be the first to admit
that her life was a mess.
And that honesty, that is root to me, is enchanting.
And I love to fix messes and like I’m OCD
about cleaning up messes.
Film Courage: Well, I thought Laura [Laura
Jaconi, the protagonist played by Vera Farmiga
in BOUNDARIES] was very good at keeping things
together despite the circumstances.
Vera: Barely!
Film Courage: She seemed to be getting things
back together and then it would fall apart
again?
Vera: She was striving to at least.
Film Courage: Well, it was enjoyable to watch.
Shana, I know you received your MFA from UT
Austin [master’s degree in creative writing
and screenwriting]?
Shana: Yes.
Film Courage: How has your writing changed
since those college days?
Shana: Well, I was a horrible writer.
I mean really, truly horrible.
Like unreadable things I wrote back then and
I think that’s one great thing about writing
is the more you do it, the better you get.
So I teach occasionally and that’s the advice
I give to all my screenwriting students, just
keep writing because you will get better.
And I’m looking forward to in 30 years when
I write the most beautiful, epic screenplay
ever because I’m going to be that much better
then.
Film Courage: What about acting?
How do you feel that you’ve evolved from
last year or when you first started?
Vera: I don’t think about that at all, I
don’t.
I try to evolve as a human being and I try
to attain as many skills as I can.
I try to work on myself and understanding
my own foibles and transgressions and ineptitude
and you try to self-diagnose often so that
you are good at diagnosing your characters.
But I don’t know if I think about if I improved
in acting?
I think I’m only as good as the writing
and in my scene partners.
Lewis: I think I’ve certainly learned a
lot from getting to work on this film and
getting to work with the amazing cast.
And like Vera said it’s your screen partners
and getting to work with Vera and Chris [Christopher
Plummer plays the father Jack Jaconi in BOUNDARIES]
and everybody you know absolute legends.
They force you to bring your game up to match
their level.
Vera: And I think the only thing you are thinking
about as an actor is what’s my objective?
What am I supposed to convey?
What’s important to fulfill in this characterization?
I don’t think you think about am I being
a good actor or am I doing a good job?
I think you’ll be doing a good job if you’ve
figured out what the obstacles are and what
your objectives are and what are the character
traits that you were trying to convey.
I suppose that’s the way we think about
it.